what about from your like
from your daughter's perspective do you
do you uh think about the world where
and now
and what kind of world you're gonna
leave them
i do do you worry about it i do yeah i
do
i do when i see these uh protests and
riots and chaos and so much
so much uh anger in the world today and
then particularly today i think
because of the the pandemic and the fact
that
so many folks are out of work and
through no fault of their own and
can't make ends meet and just people
feel so helpless and angry
it's uh a particularly divisive time
it's a particularly turmoil filled time
and uh it just doesn't seem like the
world of a year ago even
just feels very chaotic and dangerous
and this
and it's a small thing like in terms of
the like the possibilities of things
that could happen to the world like a
pandemic
like the one we've experienced it really
just doubles the amount of deaths
on a bad flu year so it relatively
speaking
is a small thing comparison to
super volcano eruptions asteroid impact
a real horrific pandemic or one that you
know
really wipes out millions and millions
of people
it's um it's stunning how fragile
civility is it's stunning how fragile
our
our society really is that something
like this can come along some
unprecedented thing
unprecedented thing can come along and
all sudden everybody's out of work for
six months
and then everybody's at each other's
throats and then politically everyone's
at each other's throats and
and then with the advent of social media
and
the images that you can see you know
with the videos of
police abuse and just racial tensions
are an
all-time high to a point where like if
you asked me
just five or six years ago like uh are
have
racial problems in this country largely
been alleviated i'd probably say yeah
it's way better than it's ever been
before
but now you could argue that it's not
now you could argue no it's way worse
in just a small amount of time it's way
worse than it's ever been during
my lifetime you cut well while i'm aware
of it you know obviously when i was a
young boy in the 60s they were still
going through the civil rights movement
but now uh it just seems
very fever-pitched and i think a lot of
that is because of the pandemic and is
because of all the
the heightened uh just tension
the one i liken it to is
um road rage because you know people
have road rage
not just because they're in the car no
one can get to them but also because
you're at a heightened state
because you're driving fast and you know
you're driving fast you know you have to
make split second movements and so
anybody doing something
like what people go crazy because
they're they're already at an eight
because they're in the car and they're
moving very quickly
that's what it feels like with today
with the pandemic feels like everybody
is already at an
eight so anything that comes along it's
like light it all on fire
you know burn it down like that's part
of what i think
is part of the reason for a lot of the
looting and the riots and all the chaos
it's not just the people out of work but
it's also
that everyone feels so tense already
and everyone feels so helpless and it's
like
you know doing something like that makes
people
uh it just it gives people
a a whole new motivation for chaos a
whole new motivation for
for doing destructive things that i've
never experienced in my life
you